what i look for when having ideas
are is this in flow is it easy and
magical things happen like synchronicity
like this they give me the recipe and
then oh my god you know one of my
friends in austin
got laid off she's been in the food
business she's already found a
manufacturing plant all of this within
two weeks
it's literally like you are in this
system of flow
and and i just roll with it like okay
let's see what happens and that's what i
look for when it's hard
and difficult i kind of go i don't know
about this right it's
that's a sign to me um doesn't mean you
can't do it
it just means you don't have the
universal flow
backing you up right i believe that each
and every one of us has
the power within ourselves to create the
life that we
really want and i want to help give you
the tools to make that happen
i'm danica patrick and i'm pretty
intense
today on the show is the very
inspirational
susie batisse she started poo-pourri
which i know all of you have in your
house
and she also has another company called
supernatural which is a cleaning product
and for any of you who are interested in
diving a little deeper she's also
offering at 75 percent off a course
called
a live os which is um
something that she says has been 15
years in the making
of um of a course to help you dive into
yourself
and of course then what we get into in
the episode really is how
it's the inside of what's going on
within her
it's her emotional state it's her
ability to feel flow that gives her the
ability to be the business mogul that
she
is that's all secondary to looking at
herself so in this
in the episode we talk so much about um
that we talk about her journey we talk
about everything from
ayahuasca to a 500 million dollar
company called poo-pourri
but at the heart of it all while wearing
her
crown also known as her hats uh
is the story of a woman who
has been through it all and come out the
other side and is here to
be an example of how we all need to
learn how to become
our own guru thank you so much for doing
this it's so nice to meet you i can't
wait to meet you in person
i know me too i feel like i know you
kind of
well maybe there's some kind of
existing resonance with spiritual people
i think there is for sure right i think
it has to be right because if everything
is in
in terms of frequency then you know
we're kind of
we're we have this we have a similar
vibe oh 100
that's why i think so it's like oh yeah
i know her like we're the same
this is great my um
my friend stacy was the one who
introduced me to you
and got me following you even though
i've actually had
poo pourri for give me the timeline when
did it come out when did poo pourri come
out
well i made i made my first bottle in
april
of 2007 or sold the first bottle april
2007
so it's been what's this 2020
13 years i think i've had it for that
long
really so my friend back in roscoe
illinois had
a little gift shop and she had all kinds
of different things in the gift shop
and one of them was poo-pourri and so my
sister was just i was just on the phone
my sister today and she's like you know
that shirt that i have about that one
marathon
and it was from the shirts date is 2008
and that's the year that zazu
opened which was the name of the little
gift shop she's like it had to have been
at least 2008 and i thought
i i just think it's been around for 15
years for me
so i mean it's i mean and now it's like
like a 500 million company yeah
yeah and thank you for buying it back
then oh yeah because
seriously like i love everybody that
buys it now thank you so much but i also
think those first people that took a
chance on it right
because i wouldn't be here man it was
like magic
when it came out it was like magic you
put in your like it's just magic it
somehow it just like seals it up and
it's like
magic and then of course on top of that
i
i'm i used to be a race car driver and
uh so at the race weekends
we'd all live in buses and so when you
live in a little tiny bus
you need brewery oh yeah i bet
yeah for sure that saves we've had a lot
of
musicians and people that are on tour
and buses
email us their managers like can we
please get some poo pourri
exactly so how are you i'm
really really well i i feel great
you know it's some really challenging
times for
you know a lot of people for everybody
you know in the world right now but i
feel
really positive and full of life and
light
and using this time to really harvest
and
you know plant some seeds realign so
that whenever we come out like
you know guns are blazing
what seeds are you planting oh
lots of seeds the funny thing is i
actually have two new companies i've
started during quarantine
one is already almost i mean it's oh my
gosh
it's it's about there and another one is
a really great concept where i have
names we're working on branding
so that my personal story working with a
lot of people on my personal story how's
that going to get told in the world how
do i want to tell in the world
i have the alive os course which is
stands for live operating system
which is basically a course that i wrote
13 years ago
that i rewrote and took a few women
through it last year that's going online
and then poopery and supernatural
that's all what are what what are these
other companies like can you give
any kind of indication since we just
know we're all going to want to buy it
because we all want to buy everything
that you create
um what what what boxes do they fit in
are they
products is it like is it more like live
os
where it's kind of interaction or can
you no
they're all completely different one of
them is cookies i'm getting in the
cookie business
okay paleo gluten-free vegan dude wait
i'll send you some over we're we're in r
d now so i will send you i'll curl your
sim over like
incredible cookie miraculous story i
chased this recipe for a year
because i tasted these cookies in new
jersey in this little tiny town i
offered to fund this girl
do everything and she ended up closing
her business
i offered to buy the recipe to this
cookie like this cookie's insane
and um super simple ingredients but it's
literally perfect
and long story short i chased it for a
year and
two weeks ago i texted her three weeks
ago and i just said hey you know what
are you gonna do with that cookie recipe
and she goes in the spirit of giving and
she sends me the recipe
for free so i'm like
now i have a responsibility to do
something with this cookie right
it's like this is some universal
gift that i'm now responsible for if i
bought it i wouldn't feel so responsible
well i mean it doesn't sound like the
recipe needs any vetting out or testing
but
um if you need like reviews uh
something like that my boyfriend loves
cookies too
you know good yeah we'll have to send
you over some cookies they're insane
they're really really
good so i never thought i would be in
the food business uh but
yeah that's happening and it's so cute
yeah
it has a lot of aliveness you know i
really follow that alive energy and this
is alive
so even though it doesn't make sense
like in my portfolio or
you know what i would be the business i
would be in it just it's alive so
i'm just gonna go with it ian's
perspective alive you're saying like
it's
so natural it's supernatural
but it's uh is that what you mean what i
mean alive
um is things that i look for things that
happen in magical ways and i
look for this it'd be interesting to see
if you felt this in racing because a lot
of surfers feel it
you know i don't know about i don't know
anything about race car driving
but you know how like when you surf and
you're looking for that perfect wave and
you can get in the zone
so anytime you're doing any sort of
sport like that you really get into flow
and what i look for when having ideas
are is this in flow is it easy and
magical things happen like synchronicity
like this they give me the recipe and
then oh my god
you know one of my friends in austin got
laid off she's been in the food business
she's already found a manufacturing
plant all of this within two weeks
it's literally like you are in this
system of flow and
and i just roll with it like okay let's
see what happens
and that's what i look for when it's
hard and difficult
i kind of go i don't know about this
right it's
that's a sign to me um doesn't mean you
can't do it
it just means you don't have the
universal flow
backing you up right to me it's the
difference between
learning to let something go
versus calling it quitting yes because
like that's how i felt about the end of
my career was
i could keep going or i could just let
this go
because there's a lot of signs telling
me to let it go i can force you can
almost force
anything right anything yes but when
so how did you how did you learn to even
have that kind of gauge
yeah i'll tell you um you know my story
is you know i've
been bankrupt twice when i was 19 and
then again when i was 38
and you know i have that challenging
life i always say i checked all the
dysfunctional boxes
so life to me up to 38 years old was
extremely hard
and i developed a really strong muscle
of pushing through and i'm going to make
it and i'm going to
so anyway my second bankruptcy 38 and
invested all my money in this amazing
idea that was a dot-com it wasn't my
passion but it was a good idea
again no it wasn't alive for me but it
was a recruiting platform that matched a
person's culture with a company culture
it was 20 years ahead of its time but it
was genius back then you know
but anyway the stock market crashed lost
everything
went into a spiritual sabbatical and
really i was done i was really one of
those moments where i got down on my
knees to god
and i tried to kill myself when i was 21
but after i had children a family i knew
that wasn't an option
but i was like i'm done like god you
need to really take me because
i can't do this anymore i was exhausted
from all the pushing and striving and
going through and then um
you know i started this path of you know
i read a man search for meaning by
victor frankl and then
i was in byron katie's workshop loving
what is
and i found peace and happiness within
my being for the first time in my life
there was no desire for money success
anything
i literally was just at peace i didn't
need money i didn't need wealth before i
thought i needed wealth
in order to be somebody
right i thought if i can ever just get
rich
then i will feel worthy within my being
so then poo-pourri came along and what i
realized is if i can lose everything
the i'm not gonna do it the same way i
did it before i'm gonna have fun
because when i lost everything when i
was 38 i looked back and i said what's
worse than losing everything is losing
everything and realizing you didn't even
have a damn good time doing it
right i was exhausted i was burnt out
you know it was horrible so i didn't
have anything so then when i said if i'm
going to go back in business i'm just
going to have fun
that's it i'm just going to have fun i'm
going to go with the flow if it feels
good i'm gonna do it if it doesn't
i'm not because the [ __ ] can just get
wiped
out at any second so that was when i
began that philosophy
i'm like if it feels good do it and if
it doesn't i'm not
and you know not saying i'm a hundred
percent it's like a yoga practice one
day
you know the pose is perfect the next
day i fall in my head
yeah exactly but it's difficult it's
definitely a principle that i practice
you know i have overrode at times you
know because of fear or something but
generally speaking
if it doesn't feel good i'm not having
fun then
i'm not gonna do it that's the thing
with this cookie it's fun it's easy
so like why wouldn't i get in the cookie
business and if it's hard even if it's a
great idea if i have to struggle
and it's hard that already tells me
right there of what the whole trajectory
of that's going to be
right and i don't even want to get
involved in that
it's like no i've been there i can do it
i can do it but what i want is that
magic
and that spark of aliveness
that really is it's like being in flow
with the universe that's where i want to
play
no matter how much money i make yeah
yeah i feel like abraham hicks is coming
to mind like everything abraham hicks
like the
trajectories start the day off right in
flow like that's though
that vibe of just flowing but it makes
me think of
these two dynamics which you know i'm
just thinking about it from a little bit
of
my experience but then asking for for
your perspective
and that's it if it's difficult and i
feel this way too in business like it
just it's to me
signs that you're not on the right track
and then i think about this on the other
side of the spectrum being relationships
like personal relationships and when
that's hard
is that the sign or is that the sign
to look within yourself
yeah well i will tell you um don't ask
me about relationships i've been married
three times
so i even
just broke up with my boyfriend so
that's an area i'm really practicing um
so we're not gonna talk about that but
we'll talk about business
um you know it doesn't mean that you're
not gonna work
hard there's a difference between it
being difficult and you having to push
through
than it being like let's say you have a
child
you know it's like you have this love
and passion for the child you have the
universe behind you
you know some universal force help form
it in your belly so you've got this
natural flow going
and you're gonna have to get up
sometimes at three in the morning and
you know change a diaper or nurse or do
something
so it doesn't mean it's not going to be
challenging but at least you have a
level of flow and passion behind that
hard work
that helps keep you going so that would
be the barometer and as a matter of fact
that's the reason i broke up with my
boyfriend right now is
it was challenging and i was learning a
lot about myself but there also were
some dysfunctional patterns that weren't
healthy
so it's like if we could overcome that
that's great but at some point when you
can't
then we have to part ways you know
maybe we'll regroup at some point but
that's the way that's what i've been
practicing
i think every experience that we go
through danica is a learning experience
every single time everything
when did you when did you know you were
spiritual
because christian household right huh
you grew up in like a christian
christian i grew up in
really conservative church of christ
tradition where if you wear shorts or
listen to music you're going to hell
so the weird thing is everybody else but
church of christ was going to hell
but also if you wore shorts or danced
you were going to hell too so you were
screwed no matter
however you did it you know like you
were just you're just going to hell
um i was actually molested when i was um
an adolescent and i used to pray every
night to
to god that it wouldn't happen to my
sister right
and then when i found out it did i
really turned my back on god
and any sort of higher power i was like
hey screw you
you know this can't really exist so then
i was on my own then i became tough
cookie i'm gonna push through everything
on my own i didn't have any support
you know and after my second bankruptcy
i went to a hypnotherapist and he said
the problem is you have no meaning in
your life
and i said what are you talking about
like i have kids i have a family and he
goes no no
no you don't have a higher power you
don't have anything to hold on to right
now
so i read man search for meaning and i
was like huh
so then i started studying religions i
started studying metaphysics i studied
you know buddhism and kabbalism and
hinduism and i just really started
diving into these belief systems and
seeing a really common pattern
and i just once i got the craziness out
of my head
all that chatter from being a victim
story
and a lot of things i started healing
there was a
natural uh i had a natural belief system
and some sort of higher power
i don't know what that is i still don't
i'm not religious i'm very spiritual
but it it helps me understand the magic
of nature
or just of life or existence you know
and then that's when i started being
spiritual and realizing
that that's all there is it's funny
people know me as an entrepreneur
because i'm like if you're ever around
me spirituality and personal development
is probably 75
of my life 25 is being an entrepreneur
because i really believe and i know my
direct experience is when i
clear inside my external world reflects
that
so my commitment is to my internal
vibration and my internal process
and it happens to manifest in magic
cookie companies
obviously that is that that is the
outward
um thing that we all see but for someone
like myself or
or my friend stacy who really resonates
with you it's the spirituality
that we are really interested in and um
it's everything it it i mean it's it's
your inner compass
it's you know it's it's what forces you
to it
gives you the ability to listen to that
um perspective on whether or not
something is being forced or you need to
and or you need to let it go otherwise
you're just in the
sort of masculine dominant force force
mode
and you know to me spirituality
welcomes in and brings such a better
balance especially with the feminine
which you know comes through nature and
allowing and
you know you said in nature and it made
me made me think of
and how that's all there really is and
it made me think of how you've been
through so many
ayahuasca ceremonies and you're very
open about that you're open about
microdosing psilocybin you're doing a
new ketamine treatment that's
that i know nothing about um so where
did ayahuasca come into that
and from what i understand it was so
long ago we didn't even know
like what the heck this was when you
were doing it
yeah i always say i started it way
before it was cool so how were you when
this when
when you just told the story about
reading the book
and going inside and realizing that you
know you needed to heal
yourself how were you yeah i was 39
so it's about on par usually when we get
about 40 we kind of start waking up
like hold on what am i doing so you know
i'm pretty predictable that way on
course
um i think that's i think that's
i think that's assuming too much really
everybody does
yeah it's a hard journey and it's not
everybody wakes up
yeah yeah well i think
you should if you're listening start
waking up because
my experience is you can either wake up
voluntarily or you can be like
me and life's gonna give you something
to wake you up right
either way you're gonna there's an
opportunity to wake up
yeah could just be listening right now
so and you
this could be what you were called like
this is why you're here today because
you were here to hear this math
you needed to hear this message totally
and yeah i don't want anything like that
to happen to you you know
and my experience is you know we're all
here to wake up i really believe that
um where did ayahuasca come in yeah so
ayahuasca came in i started poo pourri
so that was you know what i said 13
years ago
and my son was in a really dark place so
i was already happy blissed out
everything was great i was starting my
healing process with therapists
because i had a lot of stuff to heal and
um
but i was happy you know i was really
happy
and my son was in a really dark place
and i wake up one morning
never had heard of ayahuasca and i hear
ayahuasca
and dustin and i was like like it was
like a voice
like the profound voice of god or
something
and i went in and i typed a w
a and google because i couldn't even
spell it like how you spell ayahuasca
right
i still can't yeah it's a-y-a yeah so
we're like
yeah but i was like and i came up with
this article from national geographic
called to helen back
and it was about this reporter who had
depression and she had gone down to the
jungles of peru
and drank some medicine and it was
cured so i sent it to my son that was on
a wednesday morning on saturday morning
he was on a plane down to the jungle
10 days 19 years old no cell phone no
wi-fi
i didn't go with him i'm like go honey
because he wanted to go
and i was like and he calls me and he
was really like
f god there is no such thing like really
goth
you know and he was really angry
and would do um he would take
photographs with him with tourniquets
around his arm and needles and i thought
this kid's just going gonna end up on
heroin
[Music]
you know he wouldn't go to therapy so
anyway i sent him down to the jungle
ten days later he calls me from aikido
says this little jungle town down in
peru and he's bawling danica his heart's
blown wide open
i get teary right now his first words
are mom
god is real and like right now i still
cry i was just like
what like what is this stuff i didn't
even know
right i just listened to this voice and
sent him down there
he comes back and i talked to him till
like 3 a.m like i would a guru like
what happened what about what you know
what what happened
and about two months later i went down
there
and then i started journeying and i've
drank ayahuasca over 100 times
um since in my first 35 journeys danica
were like getting my butt handed to me
over and over i mean this is something
that so many people have never
some have never heard of for sure yeah
and then if you have
there's just thorough curiosity for it
right like i want to know what you
went through i want to have just like
give me the set and setting like i've
heard that's important
set and setting and then what happens
like yeah it's
ayahuasca all of these plant medicines
should always be
done in ceremony with a professional
right so this was a shaman down in peru
in the jungle
with a group of people probably around
20 people
um and you you know you drink this cup
of
it tastes like tree bark you know the
first time you drink it
and um and what the amazing thing about
ayahuasca is you would do it once as a
drug if you thought it was a drug and
you would never do it again
because what ayahuasca does is it
only deals with your subconscious mind
so whatever is in your subconscious mind
it brings forward
so you want to talk about guilt shame
oh boy oh boy yeah so you can go through
some
pretty hellacious times right depending
and i had had such a hard life right
so i mean the things you've said i
haven't i haven't even addressed them
but they're heavy like i want to give
that that that moment to tell you that i
hear you like you
you went through it and you know you've
said some things
in these few minutes that we've already
been talking that you know
could have a whole we could spend an
hour just talking about
one of them so so much respect for your
for your where you're at now and your
willingness to
figure it all out yeah thank you yeah i
mean i've
yeah like i said all this functional
boxes i checked
so what happened is even though my
ceremonies were really hard
and the reason that article was called
to hell and back is because you go in
and face your own personal health
right every single time but what
happened is at the
end there's some reclamation and it's
like there's a little piece of yourself
that you get back
so when you were or were as broken as i
was
from so much life trauma i mean really
if you if you stacked up i'm gonna send
you a list of everything that i've been
through
it's there's a lot of ptsd there so
each time though i would start getting a
piece of myself back
my husband at the time kept going why do
you keep doing this and i said because
every time i feel like i'm getting put
back together again
right and i really thought i was going
to be a shaman i thought i don't know
what i'm doing in business
i need to be a shaman and this is this
is what i should be doing in the world
and a master shaman down there told me
he said you know you're going to do more
in the world being in business
that he said basically
shamans move energy right that's what
they do they look in the body
they help you move out negative energy
so that positive energy can come in
get you one alignment and um
he said you know money is energy
and business is the biggest way to move
money and you're going to do more in the
world being in business and you're going
to be able to heal
people more than you are down here
pouring ayahuasca to 20 people at a time
and i was like oh so that's why i've
always used
business as a platform
to talk about the real truth which is
our spiritual natures and our spiritual
healing
so anyway but ayahuasca is a way to face
your subconscious mind it's a therapy
of sorts it's a radical therapy it works
so you don't know what you're going to
get into the reason it's so scary is you
don't know what part of the subconscious
mind it's not like you can go in and go
oh i want to work on when my dad called
me fat
you don't have that choice you drink the
ayahuasca and you go on a ride
and you know this the ceremony can be as
simple as
like i used to lie a lot when i was
young and one ceremony danica was just
me literally seeing every lie i had ever
told my entire life
just like live life
like it was like and you're just like ah
like i'm never gonna lie again you know
so it's things like that and it can get
as you know there were
um some some very heavy things that i've
done
i you know that have come up in
ayahuasca lots of shame and guilt and
remorse and
also there's great ceremonies you know
but you just don't know
but it is a it's a healing path
and if you're drawn to it do it in a
safe environment
with a professional that you trust and
if you're not drawn to it
why would you go through that
right because you care about the other
things that happen too
with purging and you know being scary
right like if you hear that where it's
very scary
having the shamans is that they make
sure that you know they're they're your
safety net
that you're not just gonna wander off
and stay in the trip
and like do something crazy yeah oh yeah
there's like
i mean that's the only way you should do
it is in a safe environment where you
feel safe
um anything like that yeah yeah yeah
well it's definitely what do you think
about it now because it's become
you know we we were our whole family our
whole family
drank together quite a bit and we went
down to the jungle for about six years
and then you could feel it turn into
tourism
you know like you you could feel the
shift where it was different
and then it was like oh you know because
we were down there mostly
back in the day there were psychologists
and reporters and
national geographic photographers they
were all explorers
right and people were there to heal like
to truly heal
now i think it's a little bit of a sport
um but still the medicine's still
healing
so whatever it's just i don't go down
there anymore yeah
well now you're doing i was just
listening to um
a spiritual shift is that what you call
it when you every week what's that
called again like holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
um and you were talking about ketamine
i feel like you're our spiritual guru so
like what's the next
what's the next thing that is
next healing modality out there
yeah i'm really excited about ketamine
i've also done a lot of mdma and
psilocybin journeys which are great as
well um there's
psilocybe mdma's becoming approved to
use in therapy
so is psilocybin if you are interested
in anything like that support maps
it's the council for psychedelic
research we really need this because i
do believe
it's uh the greatest aspect of healing
that we have within
you know our humanity right now so we
need this research so please fund that
if you
yeah these drugs get set like they get
put into this drug category
right and everything is bad and
i just think that i know but but
vicodin's okay
and oxycontin synthetic versus you know
what i'm saying
yeah yeah well and it can be and it can
be prescribed it's like come on
but anyway so and not saying that there
aren't places that that can heal
it can um but so
yeah so there's lots of different
modalities i've tried when i'm excited
about ketamine
is actually i had heard a couple people
went on these journeys it's a
dissociative
um what's exciting about it there's a
lot of research that it helps with
attachment so in relationships i don't
know if you've heard of attachment
theory
it's where you're either an anxious
attachment an avoidant
you know you come close to someone they
back off you know they back off you go
you're an anxious
and that's what i was working through
and one of my friends as a trauma
therapist said ketamine's really good
for that
so um i found this doctor out of san
francisco that's an md
and he's a researcher and he's also a
counselor and i emailed him about a
month ago and i just said hey you know
this was right before quarantine i was
like you know maybe i can fly there you
can come here
because i'm in la right now and uh he
said on pioneering telesessions
would you be interested and i'm like
well you had me at the word pioneer
okay
like i'm in so uh yeah he
uh prescribes me the pet the ketamine
because he's a doctor and you can
legally prescribe it
and then he just um gets online
and i lay there i have a person in the
house in case something goes
bad but it doesn't and you'd go on this
particular journey
what's different than ketamine than
ayahuasca
is that ayahuasca you are in the
experience if you're working through
guilt like you feel
guilt you are in the energy of guilt and
it's really
that's where it gets gnarly and
hellacious right
like you're in it you're reliving it and
and it
helps because you know once you feel it
the interesting thing about ketamine is
that you
observe it so
i know you still get the same learning
but you don't
you're not experiencing you're really an
outside observer to it
this is a pill you take yeah this um
they can either
do it intramuscular you know in a shot
since i'm not here he just sends me
their lozenges and you just take the
lozenge and
in about 10 minutes it takes effect and
i just go on
this particular journey while they're on
there a counselor
and the um or a therapist and the doctor
and then two hours later you come out
and what's amazing is there's no
hangover
there's no drogginess like ayahuasca
takes you a day if you do mdma in
psilocybin you are
out for two days at least because it's
really hard on your body
this is super easy it's really my
favorite form of therapy so far as far
as medicines
wow yeah so
find a doctor if you're interested get
mdma i mean uh ketamine
it's um you know what it feels like
danica
you know that you know when you're about
to go to sleep and it's that yummiest
deep part of sleep when you just think
yes i'm going to
sleep right yeah i do that that's it
because it puts you in a delta state
that's below theta so it's the deepest
sleep
that you can be in but yet you're still
conscious enough to be able to view and
experience
it's cool wow usually healing
and afterwards after the first time i
did it i said i think my brain has
changed
like my physical brain so there's
psychology
and then there's the physical structure
of the brain and they said it actually
is proof that it does change the brain
and what in uh in what way in a positive
way getting rid of
old um you know because an attachment is
just an old uh synopsis
that's wired wrong so it's like a
miswiring
and it helps break that wiring like joe
dispenza would say the wiring and
firing yeah like you you reprogram
essentially
100 activate things yes yeah
i know yeah i'm super into it um i don't
know how long with these things i
journey for a little bit
and then you know i just go through if
life's presenting me something let's
journey right now i'm really working on
relationship
and going back in the relationship with
my father and that's up for me right now
so that's why i'm journeying with some
of these things what's coming up i mean
if you're willing to share like what are
you working on right now yeah
so my dad my biological father was a
bipolar alcoholic
and uh really just codependency
and wanting to you know i just broke up
with a musician who had some
issues you know
trying to set issues they probably go
together
seriously no joke um trying to
save him unconsciously you know
and realizing that i was in that and
really it has to do with my father
so just diving deep into those things
and realizing the reason i was attracted
to him in the first place
and he's not a bad guy he's an
incredible guy so that's where
responsibility comes in
and going there are no bad experiences
there are
there's an experience that says hey this
is to show me something
and this really was highlighting this
area of healing within me that needs to
happen
in order so that i can feel you know
whole
yeah i've learned that i feel like
especially
in the last four to six months i've been
diving really
deep into myself my past
childhood and then the word that comes
forth for me that i've finally started
doing was
taking accountability
not for them to be fixed or fixing
someone or changing something but
to adjust my relationship with it
look at it look how i'm repeating
patterns
yes and um accountability
is just a hard one why is it so hard
well because we don't want to face
ourselves it's we we live kind of in a
victim since
a society where somebody does something
to
us right think about think about it you
know it's like everybody's
whining and griping and this person and
that person
and the president and the economy and
the virus
and the there's a lot of there's not a
lot of accountability there
so it's like you know how can we be
accountability for who we place in
office how can we accountability for the
relationships we're in how can we be
accountable
accountable for you know the way we're
showing up in our lives for
you know that we're in a but we don't
have any money how can we be accountable
for that
you know there you you've had a part in
that somewhat you know
and i think that's just it's easier
we're trained to blame it on someone
else
and it's tougher you have to really have
a tough look at yourself
and takes a lot of courage in my
experience
it's easier to go you did that
it is of course do you feel like you're
being more
brave now maybe than you ever have
or do you think that
that's saying something 100
so is it like muscle do you think is it
like a muscle that gets stronger and you
learn how to dive deeper
yeah yeah like for example when i'm
going into ketamine the
the guy actually said the doctor he was
like we haven't seen anybody go this
deep
right in the lozenge but it's also i'm
not afraid of the space anymore
because i've dove so deep with the
medicines for so long
like there's it's not a lot for me to be
scared of because i know that whatever i
see
is there to serve me and i'm going to
heal true so it's
so it's like i'm a little i'm just not
as scared to
lose control and i'm i'm anxious like
come on let's go
let's show me show me what i need to see
so then that was developed over a long
time in muscles and the same thing with
therapy the same thing in relationships
like i dove into this relationship
hard like let's like it was full like
cannonball let's go baby
and you know that's beautiful it's
gorgeous
i love what i did i love how i loved and
also there were some really big
learnings for me it's like oh
okay let's go back and retweet susie
because your radar is a little off
and then i'm like you know what but it
served some purpose
and yeah it's all part of the learning
like you said every experience you learn
from
and i mean especially if you're slightly
awake you learn from them
um well but my choice is to
learn yeah um because otherwise i keep
repeating them
yeah you know and i just want to learn
and let's
grow and move on and have love and light
and
let's all go and be happy you know so
when i
because i mean my spiritual journey's
been by no means um
as deeper as you know as long as you've
been at it but for what i have been at
i have these waves of feeling like
oh my god it's so much work and it can
be really really dark
really emily's just really sad like i
would say for me especially in the last
like
four or five months i i cried a lot of
days
like it and so do you ever get the
feeling
like oh my god when's this gonna be over
this is the last lesson i'll just have
to learn this one and then it's going to
be like
smooth sailing from here does that cross
your mind or do you just have this
insatiable um appetite
for what's next
think both
there are some moments when i'm like oh
my god i literally called my mentor
a couple months ago i'm like gay when
when when when when and then i realized
that that
is the process of life it is the you
know if you look at the cycles out in
nature
right you have the time that things
bloom and then you have the time that
things
die and wilt away and when you look at
it
i don't think this work will ever end i
think that
is what we're here to do so i've so at
one time sometimes i can feel
like what was me for a few moments and
then i realized like oh
i have a goal to reach my highest
evolution in this lifetime whatever that
is
so that means i'm going to keep whatever
comes up and whatever i'm having in my
experiences here to actually serve that
purpose so
let's just keep going mm-hmm
rest like i mean whether it's your
spiritual journey or whether it's
starting a
new company which you've you know
started a couple of them in the last
six eight weeks do you ever
what is rest to you maybe that's a
better question
yeah well honestly i i rested
like from november from thanksgiving
till now
i was in my corporate offices less than
10 times
so um i did a lot of resting from
thanksgiving
through the third week of february
i pretty much tapped out i fell in love
i went to a bubble i called my company
and said
i'm in love dude i'm going for this um
so i tapped out and had a really
wonderful time
um and i love that my executives know me
enough to know like oh boy this is big
right okay we got you um so i feel like
i really rested then i gave myself that
luxury
and now it's just like after all that
rest i just
feel renewed so now i'm like
gun's a blazing let's go right
so again i think it's so cycles of you
know that was a real period of
really detaching and letting go going i
don't want anything to do with any of
this
anymore i really let my whole company go
i was like call me if you have an
emergency but i gotta tap out for a
while
and i left the company november december
january
probably about 90 days about three
months that's amazing
yeah i feel like all of these things
that you're talking about are just
such good lessons for us all to hear
because
you're in your
showing that you can still be extremely
successful
still be a boss still be a lover still
be a spiritual
seeker and still take ayahuasca or
ketamine or whatever all these things
are
and still be an amazing human a
successful human that we all respect
because
i don't know if you know any one of
those things could be judged but here
you are embodying all of them and
showing us that
it's possible yeah do it all
did this feel that yeah i've never
actually thank you for
seeing that i've never had the one
anybody reflect that back
but that does feel true
um and that's the reason i don't like
boxes like susie's the entrepreneur
i'm like no no no no no there's
multi-dimensions of
us all right we all have that i'm also a
mother
you know i'm a mother i'm a mentor i'm a
spiritual seeker i'm
a you know i've got all these iterations
of myself
that all play well together but at the
center
is that core that's just the solid my
solid being
and it's like you know just different
iterations of ourselves
how do you keep how do you keep your
space
clean so that you can keep
being artistic and keep seeing
the truth within yourself and others and
not getting
right there's so much noise out there in
the world there's noise with the news
there's noise with
you know drama i mean it's drama going
to the grocery store right now with your
mask on like
there's just so much noise that goes on
that
for me it's i mean i have to make a
conscious effort to
you know keep the energetic space clean
do you feel like you have to do that
and if you do like what are those things
how can we how can we learn from you to
be able to
tap into our truth which might be love
it might be work it might be a journey
you know yeah it might be all of those
journey at work while you're in love
there you go um
depending on who you worked for there's
lots of people in silicon valley micro
dosing at work
um yeah so i i haven't had cable
or watched television in 20 years
so i don't watch the news i don't ingest
the news
i don't have a single news channel
anywhere
on my phone computer anywhere um
a lot of people say oh you're naive
you're not in touch that's actually not
true
people tell me what i need to know trust
me there's enough information
out there what i realize is i'm very
sensitive and i'm very
uh easily influenced so
i realized that whenever i would watch
the news like i just felt
horrible and i was like why am i
watching why am i
putting this you know it's called
programming for a reason television
is called programming so i'm like why am
i working so hard
programming my mind in a positive
mindset but putting in negative
information so for me
it was a conflict so i haven't watched a
violent movie
or a scary movie in decades i just don't
do that
um i just so i keep it clean that way
also uh trying to live integrity as much
as i can
you know watching um watching myself and
how i operate
cleaning up really quickly of anything
that i feel bad or guilty for or
shouldn't have said
uh taking extreme accountability and
responsibility
making my amends um
just i try to keep my being as
energetically clean and clear as i can
you know if i feel guilty about it or if
it keeps trolling in my mind i'll have
to out myself like you know i told you
that
and because i didn't want you to believe
this so i will actually
have those conversations oh dude i've
had conversations where i'm about to
puke in a trash can
yeah my mentor gay taught me that when
you're sick you should do a account
within yourself
and see where you've been out of
integrity in your life check in and see
what pops up and like there's some stuff
that can pop
up girl and yeah
i've literally had some conversations
where
we can get into that at another point
but um
some pretty gnarly conversations and
amends that i needed to make things i
did that
i didn't realize i felt guilty for that
actually still resided in my
consciousness so
if you look at your consciousness or
your vibration or your energetic state
just as you do your physical body you
keep it as clean as you can
right you know i that's what i do
try to keep all that clear and i really
do surround myself in beautiful
environments
i try to make sure i'm in aesthetically
pleasing places
for me you know i reduce negativity i
don't have anyone around me that's
negative i just don't
um i'm not the person you call to gripe
i'm the person that you know even my
children
when they call they they know that i'm
gonna say you know they're like i have
an earache and i'll say
well that's interesting what are you not
listening to
so you go into the energetic body oh
yeah yeah okay because i believe that
too with even
you know the things that are unhealed i
was just having this conversation
actually with my dad the other day as
the
talking about things that i'm healing um
and i said
i literally think of
something that's eating me up inside
or something i haven't gotten out i
literally picture it like cancer
that's it i don't get it out if i don't
say it if i don't cry if i don't write
it down if i don't
i literally just picture it like it's
going to kill me and it does
that's literally what that is you know
freud said secrets
make you sick that was sigmund freud
we talked to every scorpio in the world
then exactly
you know it's like so what are those
when you're sick what are those secrets
and do you want to clean them up
yeah i don't have any secrets none
where did you get that bravery have you
always had it
no it's just a it's realizing i think
doing so many ceremonies realizing the
extreme amount of work that it takes to
clean this stuff up
and the more and more you do that the
less you're gonna
uh do something out of integrity because
you know you have to clean it up later
you know it's like i just can't operate
that way anymore
yeah i just know what it i know what it
feels like i know what it takes to clean
it up
and i know like there's just not worth
it like no
um whether it's with somebody else or or
yourself
like the hours of crying or the or just
even like
things that get like jammed into our
subconscious or into our emotional body
that take
years to figure out or decades or what
happens most of the time which is
why you said well i said i think you
need to stop not everyone at 40 years
old figures it out
never people never figure it out you
know
danica i got to see my mother i didn't
get to
i had to watch my mother die
um really have never done any work
she was terrified full of guilt full of
shame
and it's such a horrible way to die and
i have a commitment that i will not die
like that
that's not going to happen i will have
said everything i needed to say
so i think it's that's where i get some
courage too is
is this is witnessing what it's like on
on the other way and i don't want to do
that
like no no no no no i would rather
i would rather feel terrified shaking my
boots telling you something
than for me for this to eat me up
right because it will
yeah i also imagine i don't know if you
believe in reincarnation or not
do you you know i
i mean i've done lots of reincarnation
work and i don't know i don't know
whether it's like
genetics or reincarnation but i
definitely believe
that i've had some experiences have you
ever had any past life regressions
yeah or past life information come
through yeah and it's
seemed it's real i i was doing emdr once
and a past life came through
and my therapist's mouth drops open and
i was just like
and she goes that's never happened and
i'm like
i don't know did you ever figure out
you're anything like really super cool
in your past lives
this i was a queen and i was
i was going to be beheaded by my husband
because i'd gotten pregnant with
another man's baby no it was a gnarly
one girl
oh my gosh that stuff is so fascinating
so i have no idea if it's true or
whatever but it was an interesting
experience do you believe in it
i do i do because to me it explains
things like old souls
and just knowing information resonating
in a certain way
like i don't know i have some bully i
have a feeling like
i don't know the frequency is rising on
the planet i think people are waking up
and i think the there's all kinds of
words from like crystal children star
children um
you know the there's there's a few other
ones indigo
yeah you go children um
[Music]
but i feel like we're all finding each
other yeah i didn't know it in the first
place you kind of go
it's like at the very beginning like i
can't wait to see you i can't wait to
meet you and we kind of just feel like
we resonate and like why is that or
you know people that you know aaron and
i have met in the last year that were
amazingly great friends with like so
quick and like how does that happen
um so but to sort of go back to what i
was thinking about the reincarnation
and about learning lessons is that i
think to myself and i have you listened
to dolores cannon
oh yeah okay so there's a great guy here
do you know jordan dewitt nope but i'm
going to write that down
yeah i've seen you his info he's like a
master
trainer of her work or a master past
life regression guy he's great
i was really afraid i was really sad
that one because i've listened to hours
and hours and hours of dolores cannon
and i was so sad that she was not alive
anymore because i thought if i have some
really deep stuff going on who the hell
am i going to call
um but dolores cannon does so much
she's a hypnotherapist she's passed away
um but
uh i think about her saying if you don't
learn the lesson this time you're gonna
come back and do it again
and that's what i think of every time
that i'm like i don't want to do this i
don't
i don't want to have to come back and do
this again i do not want to have to go
this life again to get back to this
lesson i'm going to do it this time
yes see sister so that's what gives you
the courage
is going no no no no i'm not going to
repeat this
that's not happening i can have another
experience but it is not going to be
this one
so true it's so true um
well what do you feel like i mean i i
you're such a business mogul
i mean you are and you're so creative
and so visionary and such a leader
um but what do you feel like your
purpose is
like when it's all said and done
i really think it's funny because i have
this written on my wall
natalie merchant has a song called
wonder and she has a line she says fate
smiled at destiny
and um i really am starting to
see that my entire story
the entire journey has been the purpose
right
it's it's literally the trajectory of
the story
the just like i get teary thinking the
honor of just being able to share a part
of it with you
like really like i cry right here just
going like oh
what an honor you know just to be able
to share a part
um and i think that's my purpose is just
to say you know i've been in a lot of
these places i've been homeless i've
been in abusive marriages i've had all
kinds of abuse
i've been bankrupt twice i've you know
and you can get out of it and you can
heal
that's my purpose is just to let people
know and be some sort of
an example that that can happen and
i just get teary on my knees thinking i
can't think of a greater honor
to live this life to just be able to
share it
to inspire you inspire yeah that's
it that is just you know
yeah it's again it just it it gets me
it's just like you know there's no
victim
story in there that's just more like i
feel such an honor
to have just be in my position
it's like yeah some sort of amazing
miracle
and then just to be able to have the
voice and ear of people
and because i needed those people i
remember back in the day i don't know if
you heard me say this on
any other podcast but i used to listen
to les brown and zig ziglar
and they were all men you know but i
listened to those guys with my
little cassette tape in my car and it
was like
hanging on with my fingernails and it
kept my nose above
water you know what i'm saying because
i'd been in such dark places
that i thought okay like it was just a
little bit of i can make it
and if i could even be a fraction of
that to even a tiny group of people
then my life feels complete
the shaman was right susie the shaman
was right
yeah i don't know it's not groups of 20.
it's groups of 20 it's groups of 200 000
at a time you know or
or millions at a time yeah
well thank you that's that's what i
really realized i had a
a woman who she's a script writing
consultant on the feminine heroic
journey
and she said there's only one reason a
person's lived the life that you've
lived and i said why and she said for
the story to be told
and i was just like it just got me i was
like
interesting we need these stories so
when i remove myself out of it from an
egoic place
i'm like yeah i needed a story like that
right yeah
we need heroes yeah i'm a giant
hero are they making a movie about your
life now there's a lot of
yeah there's a lot of things going on
they sure as hell should
look great we're looking at some series
and looking at options right now
um which is really i mean again it's
like pinch yourself moments like what
okay
yeah let's just keep just keep saying
yes so
um and i'm very it's it's interesting
how picky i am about the how the story
is told because to me it's a spiritual
journey and it's a reclamation story
it's a us reclaiming parts of our self
that we lost
right that's the story and that's what
i've done
and yes i've created money and abundance
with that
but that's not the story it's not a rags
to riches story
a rags a richest story when you know
what true wealth is and true wealth
is your internal state of being so
that's do you think that this point in
time that we're at where everybody's
stuck at home and giving us perspective
and you know making some people really
uncomfortable some people are loving it
are you over it or are you loving it i
love it i
okay i'm i'm with you i feel bad saying
that but i
i know i feel guilty sometimes i'm like
i'm really having a great time
in my jam um but
i was just talking to my sister today
and she's like
she has three little girls and her and
her husband were like
we kind of don't want it to be over and
i was like and i looked and i said to
her i was like
this is the point in time where you get
to decide what the new norm is
yes if you want it to be different yes
make it different right now there's no
greater opportunity
to reconfigure everything i told my
office
last week i'm like do we even need to go
back to an office
like should we all be working remote
like i don't know
is this seems to be working maybe leads
me to another
question i was going to kind of wrap up
but i'm but i'm curious then in light of
those
those little parts there what is the
point of
all of this do you feel like you have
an answer to that or at least a current
answer
i i do it's really interesting i was
listening to this great
series on gaia it's called initiation
and it's this
young kid who has like the 10 part
series talking about the different
levels of dimension and our reality
and love it you know it might be a bit
woo for people but
i was really digging it he said
something and it made me i don't
remember if he talks i don't think he
talked specifically about the pandemic
because it hadn't been filmed before
that
but what i really got is that in the
healing process
you have to let's say a medicine or a
therapy session you have to stop
and then you look and you assess you
take account
right and then you look at things from
different angles and then you come back
and your reality is different because of
that perspective change
sure and when he said that i thought
this is what's happening right now
we're stopped we're able to look at
things differently
so that whenever we go back things are
going to be reconfigured
you we cannot go back to the way we were
is to
it has to so i believe that this has
been a global
therapy session you know whether it's
mother earth doing it because she said
hey i need to breathe and break or
whether it's some higher power going you
guys need to stop doing what you're
doing and think about things
you know um whatever it is i just
believe that it's a it's a very valuable
time to get some
really good shifts and and and to to get
new perspectives of the way we've
been living and the way we're operating
yeah so what's the point of all this
though not the quarantine but
life oh the whole point of life
the whole like what's if we're working
and we get this paused moment where we
go
oh man i love this like i would
like my sister i i don't want this to
end then you gotta start
thinking oh i'm sure other people are
thinking like this too
but what is the point of all if if what
are we working so hard
for when it just doesn't take much it
doesn't take much
yeah i don't know if i know what the
point is yet but
i kind of feel that all of it is the
point
no matter where you're at what you're
doing that's the whole point within your
journey
you know we're all on different parts of
the wheel
you know we're all at some that's the
point
you know i remember byron katie saying
what if your purpose was right here
right now in this moment
what if that was your purpose we as
humans always want answers right there's
it's like a disease we're like but there
has to be an answer and maybe it's just
not that complicated yeah what if this
is it
it's like i'm i feel complete you know
it's like
yeah this is great if nothing else
happened other than this moment i feel
good i feel clear so
that's what i try to remember is you
know
just that's it
you know i have one goal at the end of
my life i have written up on the wall
over here
my nose is all runny um but i have
written
uh well played because that's what i
wanted my tombstone just well played
you know it was like life gave you some
stuff you did some [ __ ]
you cleaned it all up it's just well
played because because really it's just
a big
game so if we look at every experience
as a game and
here we are in this moment on the board
what are we going to do what move are we
going to make
that's it right it's being present and
going and what if that's it what if
everything is
every moment of the game
i don't know i like that perspective
isn't it nice
well played just make good plays all
just keep making good plays and then at
the end of your life it's a good played
life
exactly it's like well played just like
thank you that was good
i like that oh wait i have one more
thing okay so is the hat part of your
super powers
um you know you are a hat girl and i
know that and now i really want more
hats
yeah i'm a hat girl um
there's a great girl and do you know
terese uh teresa
foglia and malibu she has a great hat
shop
this is a nick phuket down in venice but
it's because i
have a really bad hair day so there's
two things it's great for bad hair days
um covers it all up but also
well there's three things um it does
help protect your crown chakra so like
if i'm
out a lot of times i'll wear a hat just
to kind of protect
myself a little bit just because i can
have a lot of
energy that can you know go wild and the
third thing is
my friend jp sears told me that and i
just posted
oh you know jp yeah yeah he's great
he told me that and i just posted
yesterday on the queen's birthday that a
queen wears her crown as a reminder
that she's in service of a higher power
so there's something that i like about
that like as
a matter of fact i'm getting that
written um on the inside painted on the
inside of all my hats just for me to
remember
that i'm in service of a higher power
that it's
just it's like my crown
that's beautiful oh three reasons
and really good for bad hair days
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that one is for sure like it goes
it goes straight hair day curly hair day
half day
start over 100 yep that's the way i do
so
or sometimes it's like a straight curly
hat hat
then totally and it just who knows it
just depends
thank you so much you're so
inspirational oh
thank you like what a awesome
conversation
yeah i appreciate it thanks everybody
for listening to the pretty intense
podcast today i hope you enjoyed it
if you like what you heard today and you
want to hear more please click
on the subscribe button